premio tiri premuto si va beh non so
biella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono qua vj oggi
siamo su out la strega è uscito dopo
secoli
c'è questo ragazzi allora mi spiego è il
videogame che sto aspettando da dallo
sospettando da mesi credo che sia uno
degli horror più attesi dell'anno
addirittura più di amnesia secondo
capitolo che sto aspettando anche quello
però questo qui outlast credo sia uno
degli horror più attesi pop dell'anno in
generale no forse è uscito e quindi
direi che possiamo iniziare abbiamo
comunque visto il trailer di out ass
però non ho ben presente se quelle erano
delle scene di gioco vero era solo un
trader comunque va bene era stupendo una
cosa assurda non mi dicono ho messo il
defibrillatore ma va bene sto guidando
ragazzi ci siamo voglio radio 105 dove
tutto esaurito maledizione rega stiamo
andando da qualche parte o che perfetto
c'è un castello fantastico e qualcosa mi
dice che passeremo la notte lì dentro
e qualcosa mi dice che non è la scelta
giusta però lo stiamo facendo lo stesso
non teniamo sul presente
c'è allora la macchina funziona è il
primo horror che vedo che i knicks at
mount ma silva said on line un significa
manicomio credo non vorrei fare un file
però vabbè ci siamo ragazzi c'è qualcuno
portinaio casellante mi fa passare sono
fa vj la tessera
ciao a te se la pa vj non funziona verrà
prendiamo le chiavi raga la macchina è
qui comunque nel caso possiamo buttarci
fuori dalla finestra e scappare
cosa che non si può fare 17 settembre
2013 ma non siamo ancora al 17 settembre
è un gioco del futuro fantastico non mi
conosci piacere fa vj non c'è problema
possiamo porre rimedio
devo fare in fretta forse mi controllano
ho lavorato due settimane come
consulente informatico nella clinica
psichiatrica work of di mount messing
sto per infrangere tonnellate di
clausole di riservatezza ma non ne frega
un cazzo a face rojas per me quelli
possono tutti andare a fare in culo
e poi dicono che sono volgare io lì
dentro succedono delle cose orribili non
riesco a capire anzi non riesco a
credere nemmeno a metà di quello che ho
visto i dottori parlano di una terapia
dei sogni che andata troppo oltre
rivelando qualcosa che vi aspetta al sud
a montagna la gente soffre quelli di
murcof hanno i soldi devono saperlo
tutti occhiali c'è una prendiamo le pile
in stile slider è la videocamera ragazzo
fantastico sarà epico adesso giriamo
nuovo film esp 3 by favi dei nodi o mio
ragazzi ma che grafica cia cioè io
pensavo seriamente quello fosse un
trailer ma la grafica è questa che roma
è questo è un film io giuro ragazzi devo
trovare il defibrillatore assolutamente
perché qua finisce male lo so ok ci
siamo stiamo uscendo bene direi che ci
siamo ragazzi posso muovermi il club c'è
una telecamera di sicurezza
faccio tipo solid snake alla stealth ok
non ci ha visti ma ho mancato la porta
fantastico
cos'è un computer facebook possono gare
penso che nel manicomio qualcuno
controlli la alla posta su facebook
quindi ci penserò dopo è permesso
sono il citofono per aprire con un colpo
una porta premi il pulsante sinistro del
mouse
ok per aprirla lentamente non ho letto
ma non importa
admo ok può trascinare perfetto per
sollevare la videocamera per il pulsante
destro si questo cielo arrivato va ben
poche parole per salvarne note devo far
così devo inquadrarli oggetti va
benissimo così tratto è pieno di
macchine qua fuori quindi posso scappare
ricordiamoci solo dove le entrate
aspettate insomma citofono suona
maledetto stronzo ragano risponde
nessuna citofono penserei che siamo i
testimoni di geova non è così
sfonda la porta male detto vabbè allora
facciamo così io prendo un camion e ci
sfondo la finestra di prepotenza perché
così almeno siamo sicuri che entriamo mi
sa che c'è una porta sul retro tipo
questa se infatti siamo facciamo come i
cani entriamo così potevo entrare una
particina del cane semi mettevate le
crocchette lo facevo subito quando la
videocamera acceso poi ingrandire o
ridurre la visuale con mouse sue muse
giorni a che fingono saperne ragazzi
posso fare le inquadrature hd 3d high
definition poi entriamo dai perché se
non siamo troppo fuori e fa freddo non
si aprono le porte ragazzi centro non si
può entrare io mi devo inventare
qualcosa per entrare perché non si può
entrare il mio istinto di assassin's
creed mi sta chiamando ragazzi so come
fare
ho capito tutto vabbè allora io voglio
soltanto sapere una cosa
mi sa bene che ho trovato quella nota
che mi dice che fanno degli esperimenti
e va bene però perché io devo andare
perché proprio io devo andare a
controllare sti posti non può farlo
qualcun altro non devo andare io e deve
improvvisarmi anche ezio auditore se non
va bene
siamo dentro quasi si ragazzi
non è la crudezza che mi aspettavo bene
così per attivare gli infrarossi premi f
ricordati che infrarossi consumano
batterie usati come criterio alla
splinter cell ragazzi si vede al buio
fantastico non si vedono ammazza se non
ne so molto gli infrarossi bene così e
vabbè usciamo di qua tanto qua c'è luce
tieni premuto
no non lo faceste poi legge ragazzi io
non leggo nei videogiochi io non ho mai
giocato un videogame con questa
atmosfera cioè vi girò discussi fratello
devo andare
mi chiamano sì ma frate bastava dirlo e
miranda wash non c'è bisogno di farmi
spaventare così grazie mille apriamo la
porta via di qui grazie raga
vi giuro il trailer non era una
cinematica gioco è veramente così
non ci posso credere che già sta grafica
non ci per attraversare una strettoia
muoviti verso di esse ok va bene si è
acceso un televisore o chiazze di sangue
raga usate gli assorbenti per favore
bonn noi andiamo a farci un allarme
antincendio io già l'ho premerei chi
cazzo aperto una porta
ragazzi ho sentito una porta aprirsi e
non ero io
ragazzi sta gocciolando qualcosa dal
soffitto sento rumori molesti non mi sta
piacendo aprì la porta che ti prego e di
vetro tira un calcio maledetto va beh
non fa niente rag andiamo avanti di qua
penso che io mi debba affidare nei
condotti alla solid snake per favore
lavati le mani guarda lo farei ma quelli
di fuori non se le sono lavate vedo
comunque dov'è la nutella maledetto
frigo non c'è la nutella ragazzi non c'è
la nutella andiamo avanti di qua sto
gioco los tramando sto amando sangue che
gocciola dal soffitto per raggiungere
con dottor estrazione premi spazio si va
bene lo avevo intuito ora raga adesso mi
deve chiamare il colonnello tipo solid
snake posso usare la telecamera qui sì
perché non vedo niente perfetto raga
stiamo nei condotti no vabbè questo laga
dovevo farlo perdonatemi ma dovevo farlo
se quello è bene allora nel caso nei
casi incontri qualcuno penso che mi
conoscono sono fa vj faccio video su
youtube c'è qualcuno ragazzi c'è
qualcuno che corre lo vedo lo sto
vedendo e non mi sta piacendo perché
stanno andavan tic la videocamera tanto
ci vedo c'è qualcuno di qua a praga sono
tutte chiuse porte non ce n'è una che si
apre va bene premio tieni premuto si va
beh lo sanno
successo successo ragazzi e no no no
questa mi è piaciuta
mi è piaciuta un cazzo bene c'è qualcuno
dia peso lì c'è qualcuno dia pesano
questo sarà sono studiata questo era
veramente bella perfetto abbiamo abbiamo
capito che non si scherza sottogioco
buongiorno senti non so se tu quello
quello di prima attaccato al muro ma non
sei bello ragazzi è successo qualcosa di
fantastico perché c'è il tempo sulla
telecamera vi si stanno scaricando pure
le file della videocamera malizia sono
sono con il j fermo fermo sono sono un
essere umano è uno spuntone nel collo
non so che te ne sei accorto tirerei
fuori però sono brutto ragazzi io me ne
vado ci sono delle teste ragazzi via
basta mi ha visto abbastanza fuori di
qui come cazzo si esce solo qualcuno è
entrato qui dentro non ho idea di chi
sia ma è entrato qui dentro e io ci sto
pure entrando no è chiusa la porta meno
male
no perché io ci entrò anche giustamente
ragazzi sia che cazzo
io non capisco sto gioco dove mi vuol
portare ma non mi piace la situazione
c'è un'altra porta fiamma c'è mica
nessuno qui cos'è questo batteria bene
bene bene così ok allora nel caso vi
venga in mente di fuggire lasko posto
tirando lo sciacquone del gesto
ricordatevi che rimane otturato non mi
metta a correre tipo ai di mezzo alle
colline
vabbè passiamo di qua
la [ __ ] via di qui le scarse successo
è quello no allora ragazzo noi dobbiamo
mettere in chiaro due cose non mi può
sfruttare la gente così non 66 della
confraternita oscura di skyrim che ho
riconosciuto perché io sono entrati in
un manicomio abbandonato perché perché
mio zio santissimo dove siamo ci stiamo
alzando dove è andato il tizio di prima
proclaimed e gospel non so cosa vuol
dire ragazzi ma c'è un tizio a terra che
non ha più lo stomaco
questo succede se bevete troppo in
discoteca lei è dell'umbrella
corporation
deduco di no comunque ragazzi stiamo
maida di no è tutto chiuso ovviamente
non l'hai piano di computer accesi che
spreco di energia maledizione a c'è un
tizio che cazzo città è sveglio e
sveglio ragazze un tizio dio sono fa vj
girati ragazzi c'è un tizio con gli
spasmi laggiù però non posso
raggiungerlo cedevo non è che si
apprezza porta non si apre come come
teme non ci avevo neanche provato ma lo
sapevo cioè era obbligo era cioè era
d'obbligo che non si aprisse comunque
volevo dirvi che prima in questa prima
parte era quella del trailer però lo
spavento giuro che non me lo ricordavo
neanche quindi no
babbo ragazzo a tutta la gente che c'è
qui dentro sono riuscito ancora
incontrare nessuno ma sinceramente
neanche ci tengo mio dio quanto sei
bello ragazzi e questo è veramente un
figo permesso qualcuno emes trovato nel
cesso wildness bene basta che non ti
alzi quando si dice che vomiti di
intestino quando per i troppo questo ha
preso troppo alla lettera va bene
accesso non c'è niente la gente continua
a tentare di scaricarsi e bellissimo
buona mano zions è rimasto incastrato
non te la do raga stiamo stiamo
scendendo nel nell'assurdo vabbè andiamo
avanti
sto diventando security sull una chiave
di fissare la chiave elettronica per
aprire la porta va bene poi la cerco ci
sarebbe il vetro ma non fa niente noi
noi siamo e non siamo vandali non
rompiamo le cose andiamo avanti
non credo che l'ascensore
ok invece funziona a modo suo
bene così siamo in un manicomio ma ci
vogliono canzoni da manicomio zio ce
l'hai la chiave e tu no perfetto tipo
canzoni da manicomio noi puffi siam così
si è aperto se porta ma non l'ho vista
bene così raga devo trovare l'acqua deve
essere qua la chiave per forza perché
non tornò cercato ovunque ragazzi sto
trovando di tutto ma non trovarlo sto
trovando la chiave magnetica che quella
che effettivamente mi interessa per
sbirciare tieni premuto cuore
apcom i figli tipo di questi ragazzi ci
siamo ci siamo io sono qui sono fa vj
calmo sei l'unica persona viva e calma
che ho conosciuto fino adesso come ti
chiami tu sei spencer piacere sono sono
fa vj ma matera vi la faccia alla
mattina
no va bene ragazzi andiamo via di qui
perché non mi piace vedere sta gente qui
poi rimetti a posto il vaso buongiorno
state guardando la tv cosa c'è a way met
your mother l'ho visto st puntata
sentite ragazzi ci avete mica
non lo so c'è da d'accendere buy wine
asig a zio come stai se sei un figo
ragazzi sono tutti i modelli qui i
modelli di aver capito perché piangi no
aspetti con solo io allora devi
guardarti troppo il mio video di cat
mario ti ti fa sbellicare ti giuro
sentiva beh io io vi riprendo raga
ragazzi ci siete che poi lo mando è via
italia 1 non è piaciuto va bene andiamo
avanti così perché tanto non mi tagliano
sete stronzi però è poi me la ricordo
tanto sta cosa alla faccia vostra che
non siete socievoli va bene allora ne
unico a tieni premuto tratto ragazzi
posso aprire le porte così c'è tipo
un'ansia c'è giusto per aggiungere
terrore come se non ce ne fosse salve
sull sono fa bj chiave magnetica gesù
grazie ai racconto la chiave magnetica
da un tizio molto bello siete sempre i
ragazzi bene così allora raga io devo
tornare indietro ho paura sinceramente
un po voi guardate guardate la tv
tranquilli cambiate canale che queste tv
spazzatura ragazzi sono sicuro che non
lo sapevo spencer di merda
cosa vi giuro che lo sapevo ci avrei
scommesso qualsiasi trama ancora tutto
stronzo fai come le cimici se a calci
cazzo mi sa che devo correre prima che
arrivi
gli altri sono sempre a guardare la tv
guardie bene così
echi chiudi la porta cd la porta che gli
rapporto che li ha portati via porta
spencer non ci aveva bisogno della sedia
a rotelle non è come nonno ciak più di
un po tutte le porte prestito non stava
bene ragazzi [ __ ] vi serva da
lezione ragazzi non date confidenza la
gente nei manicomi premi pulsante
sinistro per interagire vai aprista
porta non ce la faccio più ok questo
dovrebbe essere l'unica zona sicura che
non è ancora stata ok un cazzo chiudiamo
4 aspetto non si può chiudere la porta
anche no vabbè mi accontento così alla
telecamere di sorveglianza che figo che
posso vedere qualsiasi cosa mi sento un
hacker premio impostate sinistra è mosso
per sbloccare le porte principali vai
così non ci tengo a sbloccare le porte
però io voglio soltanto uscire
allora ragazzi operazione di hackeraggio
by fa dj è un caffè baby anche il
campeggio che ci sei
brutto bastardo cazzo era ragazzi noi
siamo si è attivata la luce di emergenza
non so chi era quel tizio ma che demente
che è passato qualcuno
giuro che ha passato qualcuno visto
[ __ ] chi cazzo è ragazzi sto gioco
un qualcosa di assurdo c'è veramente
incredibile lo vedo l'ora di coltivarlo
nei prossimi episodi comunque se video è
piaciuto ragazzi come al solito lasciate
un commento vi piace anche la faccia di
facebook e come individuo trovata una
descrizione sera senatur iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo prossimo
vitobello ragazzi